dea
2030年国際化していく中国に対抗数学日本政府が外国人が最も発音しにくいラ行を
ば業に変更していこう
コンビニローソンが全国的に人気を落とし徐々に姿を消したそして先週の金曜日僕が
小学時代に愛用していた上野駅前のローソンもついにミニストップに吸収
させたいらっしゃいませんそっと開いたドアをくぐって照明の眩しい店の中を見回すと
僕の他に客が4人と店員が32
スパゲティまあ一つホットスナックの前に立っていた大学生ぽいメガネのお得乳白色の
物体を指さしてそう言うと急にくしゃみのした途端にプシュッと音が c 脇に立っ
ていた花模様のワンピースの女性がさっと体を引き起もミキモト小声で言ったポイント
チップは持ちでしょうか
できたてのドーナツの臭いが漂っていた店の奥の壁には英語と日本語を交えたトーク
番組が映っていて剥げかかった司会者が大げさなジェスチャーで話していた
その声を聞くともなく聞きつつ僕は展示
oh no led が放つ光線を浴びて飲み物コーナーに向かった
どっちが一端キット買ったパン近くのパンコーナーでワイワイ騒ぐ女子校生達聞かパン
もいいなぁどっ所から学んだちゃんの木かパンにしちゃいなくても昨日も食べたんだよ
ね
マンダちゃんと思しき同氏は今の制服を着
て青いスカーフを首に巻け部分的に豚の違うお茶っ葉つにしていた
もう一方はといえば同じ制服を着て透明に近いが回ストッキング開き10年前に引退し
た時の尼崎歩みのような短い亜種形の紙をしていたがマンドちゃんも破壊ストッキング
の子もパナの高い
やや太った白人系のハーフだった
私やっぱくる三番街まんどちゃんが元気よくそういうとも高いストッキーの子が慌てて
彼女の腕を掴んだアマンドちょっと気をつけてよ
何を本体まあこの上一度お店の中を見回し
小声で言ったくるみパンって言ったよ
アマンダちゃんハッと目を大きく開け口に手を当てた空工夫
にパン私くるみパンにしようと法の施行後5年も経つというのに
私たち日本人はまだまだば業になじんでいない
なんと2週間分の栄養という波部なの前の野菜ジュースを手にして僕は電子書籍
コーナーに向かった
iphone 等にはついに登場鮮やかな発色のでー
主雑誌が嫌でも目に入って思わず苦笑した
このアポが20年前は世界一の大企業だったとは
i パンの発売当時は確かすごい人気だったが空腹が社長になった途端アップが次々と
妙な商品を出し始めあっという間にじゃあ頭が築いた財産を失う
物議をかもした間や意味不明のアイス点そして挙句の果ては卵乳が50年も前に発明し
た i pay
今度の iphone では強いの肌が一段と本物ぽくなったそうだが浮気古書が解決
しないうちはまず誰も買わないだぞ
てかさ女子高生たちが再び話し始めた口射目をした男を思い出してし
線を床に向けたまま僕はホットスナックの方に向かった
コウキくんも買ったんでしょなぜん立ったって言ってたよ
じゃあなんで私も買わなきゃいけないの極みわけわかんない後期日には何か理由があっ
たんじゃないの僕はホットスナックの前に立ちたまって手前に置いてあったミントの葉
区を一つとって野菜ジュースと一緒に電子キャッシャーかうん
他の上に乗せたドアの近くでゴミ蒸発金をいじっていた女性店員がすぐにやってきてお
待たせしましたというと企業に手を動かし始めた
4,550円が一転7,550円が一転
僕は頭の中で二つの数字をた相当したが朝の計算を店員が冴えきったポイントチップは
持ちでしょうか
ないですし
承知しましたではお会計が僕の頭の中に数字が浮かび
同時に同じ数字がカウンターの液晶画面に映った12,100円
僕は財布を出して中身を確認した
あとカバー下を3個お願いします
dee
me